joining me now is ohio congressman jim
jordan ranking member of the house
judiciary committee and indiana
congressman jim banks chairman of the
republican study committee congressman
jordan your reaction to the angle
no right on target and you're right this
is america we're always optimistic but i
i think you you captured it the
democrats are trying to destroy every
norm precedent and principle we have
think about what they've done just just
this past year in congress they've
closed the capital they've enacted proxy
voting they've kicked republicans off
committee they wouldn't let republicans
sit on a select committee they're trying
to make dc estate trying to end the
electoral college trying to in the
filibuster trying to pack the court
trying to nationalize elections as you
talked about trying to let illegal
immigrants vote and already doing that
in some locales and oh finally the
january 6 committee has altered evidence
and lied to the american people about
that information so they're they're
unprecedented where they want to take us
but the american people get it we the
people get it and we're going to stand
up and make sure the principles that
make our country great are defended and
protected as we go forward and in
november i think we're going to put
republicans in charge of the united
states congress and congressman banks
speaking of liz cheney she's trying to
rip the reins of the gop from
its own voters watch
i think the country needs a strong
republican party going forward but our
party has to choose we can either be
loyal to donald trump or we can be loyal
to the constitution but we cannot be
both and
right now there are far too many
republicans who are trying to
enable the former president embrace the
former president
congressman banks so i guess her litmus
test is
if you actually agreed with president
trump's policies
you can no longer effectively be a
republican
this is the reason i laid out the four
planks not to just be against cheney and
all of her nonsense what are we for
we can't just be against them we've got
to be four things that was the whole
point of the angle we know what they
screwed up
yeah and you nailed it your platform
nails it the pla that's the platform
that has united the republican party we
are as united and stronger than ever
that's why we're going to win back the
majority not by a little bit but by a
lot in these midterm elections the if
president trump taught us anything he
taught us that america first agenda is a
winning agenda for the republican party
the republican party made that pivot and
that's why that's why we're we're more
united than we've ever been in my
lifetime laura the republican party is
stronger than it's ever been in my
lifetime you're going to see evidence of
that in a big way on election day in
november uh congressman jordan i i do
want to get to this
point of
concealing documents
that's a big charge and it looks like
it's backed up by actual evidence
regarding what nancy pelosi may be
trying to cover up
about what happened on january 6. now i
just for everyone to understand this
congressman rodney davis office sent
this statement to the angle the house
sergeant-at-arms at the direction of the
speaker has refused to provide us their
communications surrounding january 6. i
believe those records will show there
was a lot of communications and
coordination between the speaker's
office and law enforcement officials
leading up to and on january 6.
congressman jordan what can you tell us
about this
yeah why won't the speaker's office let
the sergeant of arms office uh give us
the information give us the documents
give us the communications i mean you
have conflicting testimony from that
from that time period the the capitol
hill police have said that they asked
for the national guard to be present on
january 6 the sergeant at arms has said
no you didn't so one guy says we asked
for it the other guy says we did it the
guy who says we didn't reports directly
to the speaker and won't turn over the
documents the guy who said we did ask
for the national guard they've given us
the information so i i think that that's
what we want to when senators ask the
sergeant of arms just give us the
information guess what he said
he said you'll have to go to the
speaker's office to get that and the
speaker's counsel the speaker's lawyer
the house counsel said we're not going
to give you the information so turn over
the documents let us see what's going on
here but again remember this committee
documents they do have they have altered
and lied to the american people about
those so i don't know if you can trust
anything this committee does but we at
least like to know what the discrepancy
between these two conflicting uh
testimonies that we have congressman
banks uh related to this somewhat
president trump
has decided to
do a rally
on january 6.
given
all the emotion and the lies about what
happened and what did happen criminally
uh and some things were horrific that
happened and shouldn't have happened
that day
is it smart for president trump to do a
rally on that particular day versus next
week or the week before
i i welcome it uh president trump has
important things to say on thursday on
january 6 and uh like everybody like so
many others i'm looking forward to
hearing
what uh what president trump has to say
now just like jim jordan said
democrats fear nothing more than the
truth and that's why when that's why
nancy pelosi kicked jim jordan and i off
of the january 6 committee because we
were already asking questions that nancy
pelosi doesn't want to answer we don't
know why
she's trying to cover up many of the
facts about what happened on january 6
but we know that she's trying to cover
it up she's covering up the truth and i
know president trump has important
things to say about what happened that
day jim jordan and i and other other
republicans are still at work conducting
interviews with capitol police officers
and others to try to get to the truth
and we're going to expose the the truth
along the way that shows that nancy
pelosi and democrats
were were involved in the negligence
that led to the disaster that happened a
year ago on january 6. if we're serious
about about making sure that another
january 6 never happens again then we
need to answer these important questions
about the systemic
breakdown of security at the top ranks
of the capital the u.s capitol police
which report to speaker nancy pelosi and
congressman jordan wasn't the
sergeant-at-arms office were people
there summarily dismissed i believe i i
heard that that they people have been
there for 10 and 12 years were just told
to leave their offices at some point and
it seemed to be there was some politics
involved there
yeah the day after uh pelosi asked that
paul irving to leave the
sergeant-at-arms and the the new person
that they brought in will turn over the
documents the house counsel won't turn
over the documents but this whole thing
i mean laura think about this democrats
have objected to counting the electors
every single time a republican has won
the presidency this century democrats
spent four years trying to overturn
president trump's election democrats
spied on president trump's campaign and
they did an impeachment proceeding in
secret based on a so-called
whistleblower whose identity only adam
schiff got to know but somehow donald
trump is the threat to democracy
according to liz cheney and adam's ship
it's it's ridiculous and the american
people see it for what it is so we have
to
to make sure we get the truth out as jim
banks said about what really happened
what should have been in place that day
to protect the capital congressman great
to see both of you happy new year